bonjour à tous bienvenue dans rendez
vous chez vous aujourd'hui on est à vos
sols c'est un petit village de 200
habitants au nord de la côte-d'or enfin
que dix journées surtout sous le soleil
de vos sols on a rendez vous avec cyril
les distillateurs il vient d'ouvrir son
atelier on va vous raconter tout ça
allez on y va
[Musique]
bonjour cyril bienvenue en traîneau en
fruits
[Musique]
c'est quoi cette machine c'est un
alambic elle vient d'arriver c'est ça
oui c'est un alambic j'ai été chercher
en allemagne
semaine dernière qu'on a mis trois jours
à remonter entièrement en cuivre et inox
brossé
ça rappelle un peu tout temps les
souvenirs d'enfance sur jules verne avec
les hublots comme sa machine un peu
infernal mais extraordinaire côté un peu
alchimie aussi
c'est quoi son rôle concrètement par son
rôle c'est de transformer une matière
qui est
un taux d'alcool plus ou moins défini de
sortir cet alcool de le transformer et
puis elle que pouvoir me permet de
distiller plein de spiritueux différents
ça sent très très bon déjà je tenais
sans réellement bon là je lis tu vas est
en train de couler là on pouvait tester
pouvait m'être fait comme ça
voilà vous ok oui on en a très peu mais
on sent quand même assez fort et fort la
sas a encore un peu plus de 80 degrés là
donc
il ya énormément de force d'alcool mais
on commence déjà un petit peu à
ressentir les arômes et les parfums qui
vont découler de ce disque il
[Musique]
on voit sur la table la plante produit
est ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer ce
que c est ce que pendant vous
m'expliquer je peux me permettre de
toucher de sentir au contraire je vous
incite même à le faire pendant matin il
y a que de cette manière qu'on peut se
rendre compte des puissance aromatique
de tous les produits que de toutes les
botanistes que j'utilise ça sent très
bon vous avez le bourgeon de cassis qui
vient de quelques kilomètres de la
distillerie d'accès local c'était de la
récolte locale que je fais sécher par
des systèmes de déshydrateur s'ils
n'osent avait aussi des poires exotiques
oui c'est surprenant ria il ya un
premier goût et puis le pamplemousse
arrive après 11,7
ça reste très longtemps déjà des montres
hockey à peines et des arômes qui sont
très puissants et qu'ils ont une
longueur en bouche très longue ah ouais
c'est incroyable
bon cyril dans votre vie si vous faites
pas d'eau bénite mais nous on nous a
parlé ici d'une sainte vierge réputé est
ce que vous savez est ce qu'on
connaissait quelqu'un qui pourrait nous
en parler a effectivement c'est vrai il
reste une vierge dans le village de vos
sols très réputé je pense que la
meilleure personne
qui pourrait vous informer là dessus et
vous orienter ce serait gérard
[Musique]
cheese
sans monture fluo
là
m
tu peux
georgiana c'est loin mais c'est très
beau je savais pas qu'il y avait un
corcovado en côte d'or c'est assez
magnifique c'est un lieu incontournable
du village cette sainte vierge bien sûr
oui il ya beaucoup de monde qui vient
s'y promener mais me il ya une tous les
ans il ya une mosquée dite là
c'est quoi l'histoire de 2 700 vierge
est ce que vous pouvez me la raconter
ben elle date de 1850 la vierge de là
mais je crois que c'est la troisième qui
est sûr parce qu'elle a subi les effets
du temps ben là elle a gelé elle a subi
la foudre c'est la troisième celle là
vous vous étiez maire est ce que voilà
ça demande un certain entretien 7 cette
structure là
elle a d'abord comme c'est des pierres
qui sont montées aux colimaçons fera sec
là il y avait une vraie sur le côté là
il avait été remontée par un maçon du
village
et puis des jeunes du secours catholique
s'il faut en prendre soin bah oui bon
bah merci gérard et puis merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi on se quitte sous le
regard protecteur de la scène vierge je
vous laisse en compagnie de votre
journal régional pas de bêtises ciao